DAWID OSTROWSKI: Hello.
Hello, everybody.
Good afternoon.
My name is Dawid
Ostrowski, and I'm
a program manager in
the developer relations
team at Google.
And over the next
45 minutes, together
with two Google Developer
experts, Toys Benyossef
and Etienne Caron,
we'll make you
more aware of various challenges
that developers have while
building apps for billions.
But rather than talking about
scalability or actual user
acquisition, we'll
take a step back,
making sure our apps can
at least, potentially,
provide the proper user
experience to a billion
of users.
We will take into
account huge diversity
of users around the
world, as well as topics
like connectivity,
device capabilities, data
cost, battery
consumption, and content.
We'll be presenting
you with tools
and discussing
real-life examples
showcasing implementation
best practices,
as well as areas for improvement
in highly visible apps
from Google Play.
I would also like to invite you
to our space in the Spaces app.
Natalie, who is in my team, she
will be interacting with you
over there.
So let's start.
Probably every developer
who creates a new product
dreams about its
worldwide adoption.
Success is often defined
by hundreds of thousands
or millions of users.
But what about billions?
Is such thing possible?
Yes, it is.
Just take a look on those
randomly-selected apps-- Google
Search, YouTube, Chrome, Maps,
Gmail, and of course, Android.
Each of these Google products
is used by over a billion users
worldwide.
And what's probably quite
important to many of you
here in this room, when
I mentioned Android,
I didn't just mean
the operating system.
I meant actually, over a
billion of 30-day active users
of Google Play.
Luckily, all of those products
serve as a platform for you
to reach billions.
Your billions.
So is it possible?
Yes.
Is it easy?
No.
Established markets are
saturated with apps,
while emerging markets
have challenges
that developers around the
world are not always aware.
So even if your app
went ultra-viral
or you spent massive amounts
of budgets on promotion,
chances are your app might
not be providing them
with the experience
that would convert them
into regular customers.
Why?
Well, did you realize that over
half of the users in the world
still might experience your
app through a 2G connection?
Or that data plans
in some countries,
they can cost upwards of
10% of their monthly income?
Maybe you thought that most
of the people on the internet
actually speak English?
Well, actually, 74% of the
online population does not.
At Google, we are more and
more aware of use cases
like those just mentioned.
Our mission is to make the
world's information universally
accessible and useful.
And while we believe
that users have
the same fundamental needs--
keeping in touch with friends,
being more productive at work,
and so on-- the environment
in which they are coming
online might be different.
That's why we have
launched various efforts,
internally and
externally, that aim
at providing the best
experience, regardless
of the user's
connectivity issues,
data plan limitations,
or language they speak.
One of the examples is
offline mode for Google Maps.
Now you can download all of
area of the world to the phone,
and the next time there
is no connectivity
like underground garage
or the country road,
Maps will work seamlessly.
Whereas before you could
simply browse the Maps offline,
now you can get driving
directions, turn-by-turn turn
directions, and
information about places,
like opening hours or ratings.
Another example,
in some countries,
including Indonesia and India,
we launched YouTube Offline,
{} [? when ?] actually,
in the mobile app,
when you are signed in, you are
able to download some movies
to watch offline
later-- up to 48 hours.
Also in India and
Indonesia, we introduced
lighter and streamlined
search results
and optimized web pages.
On average, they
load up to four times
faster than the original ones
and they use 80% less data.
As our users' overall
experience became faster,
we saw also 50%
increase in traffic
to those optimized pages.
It's also very
important that you
can have a great experience
online, regardless of language
the users speak.
With Google Translate, we
help with more over than 500
million users every month to do
translations in 103 languages.
And we estimate that
with these 103 languages,
we are reaching 99% of
the online population.
So building for
billions is a challenge.
But we worked hard, we collected
feedback, analyzed data,
and learned a lot.
Now we are sharing
those insights
with the broader developers
community in the form
of an easy-to-use checklist.
You can find guidelines,
recommendations,
and best practices, for
both Android and the web,
at
developers.google.com/billions.
And remember, by adapting
those best practices,
you are not only
opening your app
for new users in
emerging markets,
but also providing a much
better user experience for those
in established markets.
So that was a glimpse of
Google effort in the matter,
but what about the
developers out there?
How do they deal with limited
connectivity, varying device
capabilities, data cost, battery
consumption, and localization?
To answer to that
question, I would
like to invite on stage
Royi Benyossef, who
is a program manager at Samsung
Innovation Center in Tel Aviv--
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
--and Etienne Caron, mobile
developer lead that Shopify,
based in Montreal.
[APPLAUSE  AND CHEERS]
[?
ROYI BENYOSSEF: Thank you. ?]
DAWID OSTROWSKI:
They are both members
of Google Developer
Experts Program, which I'm
very proud to lead globally.
The experts program-- thank you.
The experts program
is a global network
of over 400 recognized
and influential technology
professionals experiencing
Google technologies,
as well as outstanding
specialists
in product strategy,
marketing, and design.
They distinguish themselves
by frequently speaking
at conferences, sharing
their experience and passion
by publishing videos,
tutorials, writing code samples,
mentoring developers and
startups, and much more.
Experts are verified by both
Google and the community,
and they are acknowledged
through a public directory.
They benefit from easier
access to Google product teams,
are invited to exclusive events
and projects like this one,
and they participate in early
access programs, trusted tester
programs, and so on.
Some have opportunities
to indirectly shape
the future of some of
the Google products
by participating in feedback
sessions and custom advisory
boards.
Thanks to their support,
developers, startups,
and technology companies
around the world
create, build, and
shape high-quality apps.
So without further ado,
I'm leaving you now
with our top experts.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ETIENNE CARON: Hello, everybody.
So we're going to talk
about connectivity.
And as developers,
we usually work
in an ideal environment, right?
The network is solid.
We're going to test on
somewhat recent devices
that we bought locally.
And truth be told, we
often have a limited idea
of who are actual
end users are or what
their day-to-day
environment is really like.
Typically, we're only going to
come down from our ivory towers
when we start getting
reviews that look like this.
And when these reviews
start flying in,
the damage is already done.
So we're going to explore
today how to engineer apps
more suited to the real world.
At a very high level, the
approach breaks down as
follows.
So you're going to want
to surface problems
by simulating the real world
as far as closely as possible.
You're going to want to
diagnose the problem by looking
at its symptoms.
And then we're going to talk
about problem-solving and
prevention techniques.
So let's start talking
about actual connectivity.
The real world, obviously,
is a very complicated place.
And in the real
world, connectivity
is an unreliable thing.
So think about your users
on a train, in the subway,
or going up in an elevator.
Is your app really always
going to behave reliably?
What about when one
out of three server
calls fail and times out?
So let's find out.
We need to see how our
apps perform under stress.
So first, we're going to
want to slow things down.
Android emulators
allow developers
to simulate a various range of
different network bandwidths,
from full WiFi all
the way down to GDSM.
By writing a few
functional tests
and exercising those over a
comprehensive range of emulator
setups, we should be able
to find out fairly quickly
if our app misbehaves
in certain situations
and when network calls
start timing out.
The problem here,
that we're still
working in fairly
ideal lab conditions.
We don't just want
a slow network,
we need a flaky one,
and that usually
involves a debugging proxy
such as Charles, for example.
Charles allows you to limit the
bandwidth and the reliability
of your network connection.
With this type of tool, you can
control the round trip latency,
cause packet fragmentation,
random connection failures,
and just degrade the
overall network quality
however you see fit.
After running our apps
through those gauntlets,
we now have data to
work with, right?
Likely we're going to have a
nice list of issues to work on.
We now need to
investigate and find out
what the root causes
of these issues are.
When investigating, we can
start by taking a little peek
at the Android Studio
Network Monitoring Overview.
It gives us a nice idea of
what actual communications are
going on.
This gives us hints,
but obviously, we're
going to want more
detail very quickly.
Again, a debugging proxy like
Charles is very useful here.
As mentioned, you can use
it to inject flakiness
in your network calls,
but you can also
see detail, what was
sent over the wire,
the timings involved, and if
you have the right certificates
configured on your
device, you can
start inspecting the actual
SSL and encrypted packets that
go through.
Stetho is actually another
very good diagnostic tool.
It will allow you,
amongst other things,
to analyze the network
communications.
You can see the exact
timeline of requests again,
the size, completion time, all
of this from within Chrome.
One of the big
advantage with Stetho
is that you don't need to
set up special certificates
on your device and
all that extra work,
since you're actually
logging information straight
from the device.
Stress testing reveals and
surfaces potential problems
and issues with our apps,
and diagnostics gives us
the information we need to get
to the root cause and solve it.
But ultimately, we'd like
to harden our application
and architecture
it in such a way
that we'll be able to handle
whatever we get thrown at.
So knowing that
network connectivity
is a transient
thing, and whenever
a feature of our
application relies on that,
we're going to need a
strategy to gracefully degrade
the performance and
the feature set.
The end goal is really to try
to avoid surprising your users
and to stay consistent.
So let's see this concept
at work with a real app.
MakeMyTrip is an
application that allows you
to book flights, hotel, rail
tickets, and holiday vacation
packages.
We can see an example here how
it handles connectivity loss
when trying to book a flight.
We get clear and
concise messaging
with a call-to-action
to the users.
So that's nice.
There's a couple other
screens for MakeMyTrip.
Again, we have nice
clear messaging
with a cute cartoon character.
So that hits all
the right marks.
There is the question of
keeping your error messaging
consistent.
And that's actually fairly hard.
To achieve consistent
messaging, you
need to take a step back
and look at your app
at a higher abstraction
level from the get-go.
So say we're going to work
with a simple movie listing
app with three basic use cases.
We're going to have a list of
movies, of nearby theaters,
and we're going to be
able to purchase tickets
straight from our app.
What can we still offer if
we lose the network here?
So let's apply a few of
these ideas to our example.
We can definitely, using
a cached copy of data,
we can provide partial
functionality for all the movie
theatre listings, obviously.
Then, we can prevent users from
starting certain use cases,
such as ticket purchasing.
But what happens if we lose
connectivity during a purchase?
We could always kick the
user out of the flow,
but that's going to lead to lost
sales and annoyed users, right?
So let's try to find a way
of gracefully degrading that.
For the sake of example again,
let's imagine the simple ticket
purchasing flow.
Finding a number of tickets
available for the selected
movie showing is the first step.
Then we're going to
have the selection
of the number of desired
tickets to put a hold on them
for, say, five minutes.
Then the user is going
to complete the purchase.
If we take the first of
these flows and focus on it,
this is an example,
it's the golden path.
But obviously, we're going to
need to handle errors here.
So we're going to want to
be able to say try again
later if an error comes up.
But that's still
pretty irritating
if the network is kind
of flaky around our area.
Chances are high
the users are just
going to give up on
the purchase, right?
So you can make the flow
more solid by simply
retrying the server
calls when possible.
You're going to want to
be smart about retries.
Consider using
exponential backoff logic
in the right places.
I definitely
encourage people here
to explore something called
RXJava, a very fairly
popular library, to solve
that kind of problem.
When a request, for example,
finally does timeout or fail
after, say, 10 attempts,
like on this diagram,
consider giving control
back to the users
by giving them a try again or
give up dialogue of some sort.
Or if you're clever about
saving transaction state, what
you could do is give
users a way to complete
the purchase at a later time.
That saves the user a lot
of work and offering a way
to complete the
transaction later,
when the network
comes back up, people
are going to appreciate that.
So a very simple example,
obviously, but the key concepts
are as follows.
Think about the big picture.
To avoid surprising
your users, be
consistent in when you
surface connectivity errors.
Try to say the same
messaging all over the app,
keep the same messaging
all over the app.
And when an error
does actually occur,
try to save your
users' work and allow
them to complete any given
flow later, if possible.
Let's look at another
offline example.
Practo is an app that
brings health and fitness
to your phone.
You can use it to save and share
your health records or book
a doctor's appointment and find
a clinic, things like that.
Practo, in this case,
partially supports
finding a local clinic,
even if you're offline.
So that's actually great
value for end users, right?
Especially when you're
looking for a consult.
If you don't have the
network, you still
need a doctor, that's
actually pretty awesome.
Don't hesitate to be aggressive
with the offline caching
of your data.
Even if it's not
the freshest, it
can provide really
great value for users
when connectivity is hard
to come by for a relatively
low development cost.
Ultimately, connectivity
is still the game-changer.
So consider that if the
internet is not available,
it's not the end of
networking, at all.
Modern mobile
devices will give us
a ton of multiple
connectivity stacks,
so we could use WiFi Direct to
create an ad hoc mesh network.
Or you can use Bluetooth to
share files between devices.
So if your transactional and
domain logic supports it,
you'll be able to bring
great value to users,
even if you measure
network latency in days
instead of milliseconds.
In the same vein, don't
disregard MMS and SMS.
In remote areas, even slow
network can be lifesavers.
For years, nurses
in remote locations
where doctors were
not available have
been sending photos
of actual wounds
to doctors for a prognosis.
So then, that provides
awesome value,
even though people
are really remote
and you don't have a
fancy network around.
So the better we get
to know our users
and the infrastructure
available to them,
the better we can serve them.
HotelOGA is a hotel
booking management app
and is a great example of
using an alternative networking
solution.
They developed a
strategic partnership
with African multinational
telecommunications companies,
and this allowed them to
provide dedicated data-only SIMS
to their users.
Their app also works
offline and supports SMS
as a fallback communication.
So now I'm going to
hand it off to Royi.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ROYI BENYOSSEF: Don't
worry, he's coming back.
Hi.
Hello, everybody.
OK, so after we
discuss connectivity,
let's discuss the cost of it.
All applications,
modern applications,
require connectivity and
connectivity costs money,
at least when you're on a
metered network like LTE
or 3G or anything that you
need to buy a data plan for.
Let's consider the data
plan like a battery,
only you charge it with your
wallet instead of your wall
socket.
Now, there's no real analytics
about how much is too much,
but their are pain points
to notice and patterns
to notice, as well.
So app size is important.
It makes a difference.
Why?
Because if you see
an application that
is 50 megabytes and
you're on 2G and it
cost 10% of your yearly
paycheck, it is most likely
you will not
download that on 3G.
You'll wait for WiFi.
Same goes for updates.
People will delay updates
if they think it's too big,
and they might not
get the updates.
And we all know as developers,
updates are important.
So let's start with dieting,
code trimming, third party
libraries-- to be
exact, borrowed code.
Most of us take these
libraries, which are very big,
and we only use 10% of them.
So the smart thing
to do is to carve out
what you're actually
using, which
is a good pattern altogether,
because then you'll
know what you're relying on.
And it also helps to
reduce the amount of code.
Code duplicates, as
well, is a big problem.
So use Lint to find the code
duplicates and refactor them,
and you'll save 90%
percent of that.
Moving on to something a
little bit more fattening,
which are images, and it's also
a lot easier to maintain them.
For instance, use Lint to
find all the unused images
in your applications.
You would not believe the
amount of data you'll save here,
the amount of space.
Also, take your .png and .jpg
files and put them through
online compressing and
optimization engines.
Most of the size of your .jpg's
and .png files are metadata
that the user cannot see, like
where was the picture taken
or who took the picture.
If you reduce that,
you might reduce up
to 90% of the image size.
So do that.
You can also go ahead and
use more progressive formats,
such as vector drawables
or nine-patches.
Or you can either eliminate
resources altogether
by tinting, which is
taking a list of icons
and then coloring them
in various colors,
or using the dynamic resource
content coloring, which
is the palette API.
If you're not familiar
with these concepts,
then where were you in
the last 2 and 1/2 years?
Last but not least,
you can compress.
Just use the-- I can't
remember the name--
ProGuard, which is
also cyber secure
but also compresses the size.
So we've got the
diet all figured out.
Let's go to day-to-day usage.
Network usage has one
golden rule, which
is the same as in all dieting.
Simply think about
everything you're
putting into your mouth--
downloading, sorry.
Never download anything twice.
If you're polling and just
taking down information,
it is most likely you're
downloading something more
than once and that's wrong.
There are many
patterns that you can
use that help you know
exactly what changed
and when it changed, like
GCM Downward Messaging
or like staleness headers
in the server side,
or difs in the server
side, et cetera.
So use them in order to
never download it twice.
Be conscious of network type.
For instance, if
you're on a WiFi--
since we're discussing price
here-- if you're on a WiFi,
download everything.
Cache everything.
On 3G, be much
cheaper with your data
and only download what
the user has asked for
and what they can see.
That just makes perfect
sense, and you have handlers
inside Android to give
you pretty much all of it.
Optimized backend.
Backend has a lot of power here.
Most backend programmers
are like programmers,
which means they're lazy.
Simply tell them how
much it would benefit
if you would change the API
to fit only what the user sees
at any given time, and how
much it saves in radio time,
and I can guarantee
they will not listen
and you have to go
to their bosses.
But still, you'll
make a good argument.
And if we're talking
about backend,
let's also try and use
new and exciting stuff
like flat buffers or
like GCM or like difs,
or like staleness headers.
They'd like playing
with that because you
like playing with new stuff, so
they should like it, as well.
And you'll save not only
battery and data cost,
you also save
[? tie ?] performance.
Facebook and Google,
with flatbuffers,
have reduced time with loading
their own apps from up to 90%,
so not even data cost.
Now let's go to
something a little
bit different, which
is battery consumption.
It's almost exactly the
same, with a key difference.
The cost here is implicit.
You cannot-- it's not money
coming out of your pocket,
but it does have a cost,
and let me show you how.
I'm in my office, 9:00 AM,
putting the phone in my pocket
and I'm working on emails
or whatever it is that I do.
At 11:00, I check
my phone to see
if I have any calls or messages,
and I see two sad things.
One of which, I got no
messages and no calls
because I have no friends,
and the second thing is,
is that I lost 37% of battery.
That's an actual
case, by the way.
So there's a problem here.
Battery is life for most people.
People live on their phones.
So we have to be
conscientious of that.
Now, let's talk
about the tools that
will help you, as good
Android developers,
help me, as the user, avoid
these kind of situations.
So first of all,
the best example
out there is the
battery historian.
It's not that new anymore
and it's very helpful.
It tells you exactly what
portion of your application
service thread activity,
used what energy
non-efficient hardware device,
like the GPU or the CPU
or the kernel or the job
schedule or whatever.
Let's take an example.
This is the application known
as MakeMyTrip, which Etienne
already introduced you to.
You can see the amount of
data that's applied to you.
You'd know If the
device was rebooted,
you know how much time
the CPU is running.
If you have WiFi, how
much time did you scan?
What's the signal strength?
Temperature, which
I have no idea why,
but I'm guessing
[? Lonnie ?] can explain,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
There's a lot of
data here that you
can use in order to help
you know what's going on.
And just give a quick round of
applause for this amazing 1/8
of 1% result for a full
[? night-er. ?] MakeMyTrip--
I don't know if you
were here, but kudos.
OK.
You can actually
applaud if you want to.
Second thing does not
really involve around you,
but what you need
to be aware of.
Doze and standby-- and if
you don't know what that
is, please, get up, go outside.
But there are tools that were
implemented in Lollipop that
are helping the device
[? save ?] itself from you,
and you need to comply to
it, in order to be graceful
and to work with it.
The tests are fairly easy.
You simply plug in the device,
turn on your application,
turn the screen
off, and then plug
in these bash commands, which
are pretty straightforward.
Then you turn the
screen on-- OK,
it's not that simple but
they are simple commands,
it's just a lot to remember--
and then you see an example.
This is Rounds.
Rounds is a beautifully-made
video calls application
that has handled--
this is a real test.
We did an animated GIF.
Handled it, well, beautifully.
And again, round of
applause for Rounds,
because I see their CDO right
here, and he's going to--
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
Same thing goes for doze.
That was standby, this is doze.
Almost the same test, only
different batch command.
Same result, they did
their job just right.
It's possible.
It's plausible.
OK, moving on.
Radio.
Radio is the thing
that you use in order
to access the internet, so
you need to be careful with it
because it drinks
a lot of juice.
[COUGHS] Sorry, that's
why I'm with the speaker.
So it comes to a saying
that I like to say,
which nobody understands,
but I'm on stage,
so you have to hear it.
Let sleeping radios lie.
What do I mean?
These are the
practices that you need
to use in order to save
your radio and your battery.
So the first thing
is, use batch calls,
meaning that you can use
either Job Schedule, which
was introduced in Android 6,0,
or GCM network manager, which
is exactly the same thing,
only backward-compatible
for all apps that have Google
Play services from version-- I
have no idea.
Google it.
Or Sync Adapter, which
does exactly the same thing
all the way back, but it's
a little bit too complex.
It's not too complex, but
a little bit more complex
to implement.
So if you do not have
access to these devices,
use Sync Adapter.
It's plausible, again.
And it will batch
the calls together
so you would not call the
radio all the time, only
in specific maintenance
windows, which saves battery.
Never download anything twice.
Returning back, you remember we
talked about it in data cost?
So again, same thing.
Progressive server client
scheme, changing the API,
using downward GCM data, or
using GCM to update what's
changed, if it's small enough.
All of them are viable examples.
But the most important
thing is, stop polling.
Polling is the worst,
the worst thing
you can do in an application.
And there are so many patterns
you can use, so just, please,
for me, for you, no, I
don't-- for the children.
I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so after we optimize
the actual request
and the backend side
and everything else,
let's just listen to the users.
You have enough handlers
and listeners telling you
if the user actually
wants your data right now.
So if the screen is off, it is
most likely that the user just
doesn't care.
If it's plugged into
the electricity,
you can do whatever you want to,
because the battery will never
run out.
But if it's not, and you
know the battery level,
and it's low, and
you're the difference
between a brick and a
working phone, don't update.
You have activity recognition,
which is wonderful
because it's not only telling
you if the user is present
or not, it tells you context.
Because if you're
a traffic app, it
makes perfect sense to
update more while on the go,
but it doesn't make any
sense to update news scores
while someone is driving.
So context is key here and it
gives you a lot of information.
OK, now I'm handing
over the clicker
again for device capabilities.
Please welcome--
ETIENNE CARON: All
right, so, let's talk
about device capabilities.
Android runs on a multitude
of different devices.
That's no surprise
to anyone here.
There's different OS
versions, screen densities,
processing power,
memory storage-- all
that stuff can be very different
from one device to the next.
So when going global,
your user's device
will likely be very different
from one instance to the next.
You're going to need
to have your apps
optimized and flexible,
and ready to handle
all these different use cases.
So another thing to
consider, about 5
of the 7 billion people on
Earth do not understand English.
Localizing an app can be
very challenging, especially
if you didn't plan for it.
So think of the
different character sets,
of right to left languages,
and strings, once translated,
can end up 50%
longer, especially
with French and German.
So once translated, your
carefully designed UI
could very likely break.
So what can we do to catch
issues before we release?
Well, emulators allow us, again,
to configure various screen
sizes, changes in disk size,
change in memory configuration,
and the locale settings.
So all of this is great
for testing your UX.
But no emulator covers
all the different hardware
configurations that you're
probably going to see.
Think about the different
hardware and the software
drivers, or x86
versus Arm, OpenGL3,
those things are usually
not available in emulators.
They can't tell us
with 100% accuracy
how our app will actually
perform on the real hardware.
So ideally, you're
going to want to test
your app on real devices.
One approach is to build
your own hardware test lab.
That's usually fairly expensive
and time-consuming when
you think about maintaining
those devices-- making
sure they're up, handling the
random crashes, and et cetera.
So consider using a testing
lab service such as,
for example, Google's
Cloud Test Labs.
Between emulators or
devices testing labs,
we are now close to
real-world conditions.
So we're ready to test and
start hunting for issues.
For UI and UX testing,
it's challenging
to completely
automate the process.
How do you write a test that
validates if a screen is
actually legible?
Or really usable?
Or that the translated UIs
actually still make sense?
That's where human intervention
is most likely needed.
You might be thinking, wait,
if I multiply screen densities
by orientation and then
again by the number
of locales I'm going to support,
yeah, that is a lot of screens.
But if you have the proper
UX integration tests,
and that you exercise
most of your UI,
you can actually take
screenshots of those UIs
as you go on the different
devices that you're testing on
and you provide
those to your QA.
If you run a dif
tools on these images,
once somebody has
validated an image,
you only will need to look it
over again once it actually
changes and you detect a delta.
That makes things a
lot more manageable.
Benchmarks can allow you
to monitor performance
and execution time of your app.
So even if you can't run them
off of the physical device,
by keeping the actual
benchmark historical data,
you can raise alarms when
runtimes change significantly
from one version to the next.
Of course, this
means you're going
to need to keep that
history the first place.
An actual, easy
way to do this is
to use your favorite metrics
or analytics tool platform.
Using that data, then you
can write all those tests,
create alarms, or
even fail the test
if the numbers are
starting to look bad.
It's worth noting here,
on the slide you see,
that there is a dumpsys gfxinfo
info adb command in there.
That one's very
valuable when you
want to monitor the
actual performance
of the rendering of the app.
So given the range
of screen sizes
your app is going
to be running on,
your layouts will be
anything but static.
And that's really nothing new.
Web designers have been
dealing with this forever.
So consider exploring
all that great literature
on responsive web design,
and draw inspiration from it.
Think of Bruce Lee, basically.
Your layouts and content
needs to be like water.
And also, don't
feel forced to write
one layout to rule them all.
Don't forget, you have all
these local specific classifiers
that we see here on
the slide that you
can use to create exceptions
to handle those [? corner ?]
cases.
You can do stuff
that-- you can change
the layout for certain languages
which are just taking up
too much space, or accommodate
the different widths of screen
et cetera.
And here are some of the
most important strategies
to follow when you want to
do responsive layouts and
responsive design.
So alternate your layouts,
try to reuse your ViewGroups
and Fragments.
Localize the layouts when
necessary, think about left
to right-- that might
change some of those layouts
pretty drastically.
Material Design
Metrics and Keylines
are a really a nice
tool to be aware of here
when you want to do
responsive design.
Use relative, percent layouts,
dp's and sp's for text.
Never use px, please.
It's for your own good.
Nine-patches are nice and
SVGs and a vector drawables
are a very nice tool, as well,
when you want to do responsive.
For memory, I'm going
to keep it short.
Simply avoid the pitfalls.
Image loading is a scary place,
usually, and leaking context
is typically the one that
everybody gets wrong.
So keeping in usage on-- keeping
an eye on all that memory
is very important, so consider
using a tool like LeakCanary
to detect the leaks early and
keep things simple for you.
Then there's localization.
We've touched on it.
So this is a well-known quote
by French Canadian philosopher,
which roughly translates
to the following.
You'll notice it's
actually longer in English
than it was in French,
in this case, but anyway.
Proper localization
is actually super-hard
and this is one of
the areas you're
going to need to apply
some tender loving
care if you really want
to reach a wider audience.
So these are the big
challenges right here.
We've talked about the
string length variance.
Think about things like numbers,
dates, and time formatting
that will change,
depending on your locale.
So will your currencies.
You might have
currencies that are
going to be used in
different locales, as well.
You're going to have different
rounding rules, depending
on the countries, so remember
that locales are a language
and country, and think
of localization QA
and think about it
early in the process.
You want to catch that time
where the translators are
actually sending you
machine translations instead
of human translations
and charging you for it.
How will you know if you don't
speak Japanese, for example?
So you need to think about
all those QA factors.
They're very important.
So we're going to pass
over to Royi again, thanks.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ROYI BENYOSSEF:
Hear it for Etienne.
OK, so I know we've dropped
a lot of information on you
and we're running low on time,
but this is the last segment
and it's probably
the most important,
because it's the
one that's being
left behind most of the time.
How do we diagnose content?
It sounds almost irrational.
OK, Android was
kind enough to have
a lot of tools in two groups--
on device or hosted devices.
Now because we don't
have a lot of time,
I'm going to do it real quickly,
so if there's a tool that you
don't know about, tough for
you because most of them been
around for five years or longer.
So let's start with strict mode.
Strict mode simply does a border
on the skin of an application
if you're doing too much
work on the UI thread.
Simple as that.
If we look at an example,
with this GO-JEK, which
is a location-based services
application out of Indonesia,
and it's a beautiful
application,
you can see it's completely
compliant because you
see absolutely no red border
and trust me, strict mode is on.
So kudos, guys, if you're here.
Profile GPU rendering
means that it tells you
how long it takes to render
each frames in four paths, which
are creating display lists,
syncing the render thread,
issuing the display list,
and swapping the buffers.
And if it means nothing to
you, go talk to [? Ron, ?]
I don't know.
Here's an example with Myntra
that we talked about before.
Beautiful material design.
I'm going to say it a few
times, I love the app.
It's a e-commerce app.
The problem is, is that
you see the graph below
and most of the time
it's over the threshold
and then you see
peaks where it janks.
That's exactly
what's wrong with it.
Just imagine how this
wonderful looking app
would look better if it
was completely performant.
Debug GPU overdraw
is very important
because it's telling
you how many times you
draw each pixels, which tells
you what is the GPU overhead.
Well, you cannot avoid all
overdraw, but lower is better.
So MakeMyTrip, which
we did mention before,
again looks great.
And as you can see--
first of all, in settings,
it's not transparent.
It's a good thing to show.
MakeMyTrip is almost transparent
and it does so wonderfully.
But the navigation drawer
is almost completely red,
and I hope it's
because they used
the wrong third-party library,
so guys, check this out.
The funny thing is, is this one.
Look at the scrolling.
It will scroll down and you'll
see that the images become
redder as they go.
This just streams
get view issues,
and it's a perfect
example of how
you can find performance
issues in get
views which are completely
implicit to the tools.
So guys, check it out.
Otherwise, this app
is just beautiful.
Host Tools, layout
and hierarchy.
Hierarchy Viewer.
Is there anybody who doesn't
know Hierarchy Viewer?
Excellent.
Moving on.
Now, GoRide, which
we mentioned earlier,
is a wonderful example.
I love this app.
It's beautiful, it's
clear, but in this screen,
they have 14 layers.
Which means that on my device,
which was powerful and modern,
everything was great.
But if you think of a lower-end
device or an older device,
it might jank as hell,
so I would check that.
Method and event
profiling has Systrace,
which is putting the events
in the system in a timeline,
and it's very, very helpful.
It also has Traceview,
which has trace mode, which
traces the method calls,
or it can check out
through a limited time,
which is something
that's called sample mode.
I'm examining Practo,
sorry, with Systrace,
because it looks smooth
enough on my device
but you can see all
that information.
You can also see the frames.
Notice that the frames
are right on on the place
where they painted.
So Systrace actually said
that one of these frame
was delayed due to the fact
that it use too much UI
thread-blocking
over other threads,
and it had a problem with
background thread priorities,
so it was delayed
and caused jank.
This is perfect.
It actually tells you
what you're doing wrong
and how to fix it.
Allocations and
memory profiles are
very important because
allocations are very important.
Now, you have three main tools.
You have the allocation
tracker, which
is best if you have jank
in specific animations
and you don't know
how to solve it.
It will tell you
exactly what to do.
You have MAT that helps
you find memory leaks.
And you have Memory
Monitor, which
puts a visual representation
of heap usage,
and it's very
helpful for runtime.
This is an example,
again, for MakeMyTrip.
A wonderful example.
We don't have time to go
into it, but trust me,
it tells you a lot.
So let's talk about pain point.
If you have a problem
with UI responsiveness,
pay attention to
your allocations.
Use the memory
allocation tracker,
because if you're
allocating too much,
you're just starting
the CPU and GPU.
UI should not be
dependent on loading.
Decouple rendering from
connectivity is important.
Use caching for this, use all
kinds of pattern for this.
Simply put them apart.
It does not need to
impact one another.
Use the GPU correctly.
If you do not know if you're
using the GPU correctly,
that's wonderful.
Use the rendering
agent and the overdraw
to know if you're
using it correctly
and you're using hardware
acceleration correctly.
Moving onto UX.
UX is even more important.
Your app could be absolutely
performant but still terrible.
So here are few patterns to
help you not be terrible.
Material design is a
good place to start.
It alleviates a lot of aches.
You really need to know what
you're doing if you're stepping
out of material design, and
I cannot stress this enough.
Cover all end and empty cases.
If there's a reason
that you do not
have content on
your screen, it has
to be apparent as to why, with
a clear message, and preferably
a nice animation to make
the people feel better,
a call-to-action so that
they'll know what to do,
and the way to do it on screen.
So for instance, GO-JEK again.
Now, they're right.
I had no items in in
progress or completed.
They're absolutely right.
But to put a blank
screen tells me nothing.
It's just kind of disappointing.
On the other hand, Rounds have
a wonderful screen telling me
that I don't have any chats yet.
It's nice and colorful,
it has a button for me
to start a new chat, and they're
giving me a call-to-action.
Wait for it.
Start new chat.
I actually know what's going
on and what I need to do,
and that's perfect.
This example I don't have
time for because Etienne
already mentioned
it, so we're moving
on to avoiding
deprecated patterns.
I see a lot of
applications that I'm
reviewing that are
using the overflow menu,
the dashboard pattern,
the action bar.
They're old.
We stopped using them because
users don't like them,
because they're cumbersome,
because they're dated.
Stop using them.
You have plenty of
new things to go.
Practo, again, is a
wonderful application.
Almost everything is
elegant and correct.
But they're using
the overflow menu
on my phone that has
Android N. It's not even M.
And it looks dated.
It's only text.
While MakeMyTrip, look at how
colorful and wonderful that is.
I think it speaks volumes.
Last but not least--
and I'm not going
to give an example
because I don't
have time-- is find
out the places that
has a lot of friction.
Smooth them out by
understanding the users
and putting something
to make them
understand what's going on.
So now, I'm calling Dawid again
to wrap things up and mention
other stuff.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
DAWID OSTROWSKI:
Thank you, Royi.
That's all that we have
prepared for you today.
I hope you now are much more
interested in topics that
affect users around the world.
Connectivity, data cost,
battery consumption,
device capabilities,
and content.
If you would like
to learn even more,
please attend other sessions
on building apps for billions.
The one focused on
the [? web ?] will
be tomorrow at 10:00 AM,
followed by the Android one
at 3:00 PM.
Please don't forget to go to
developers.google.com/billions
to make yourself familiar with
the details and recommendations
and best practices.
If you would like to learn more
about Google Developer Experts
Program, just go to
developers.google.com/experts.
Thanks a lot for listening,
and have a great evening.
Thank you, Royi and Etienne.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]